l'igad non là une vanne j'ai failli
faire et tu vois c'est ça quand tu
vieillis un peu c'est qu'avant tout a
pas de filtre j'ai failli faire une
vanne j'ai eu tout un comité qui s'est
réuni en comité
un comité dans ma tête qui n'en est rien
on se réunit sur l'a22 de gamme
ouais mais j'ai envie de la faire quand
même pas désiré tacle alors c'est alors
que vous savez ce qu'on fait c'est pas
vous allez faire là bas même si vous
êtes le parrain ici vous êtes le taulier
de l'été sur la première c'est vont pas
trop fait c'qui ouais vous sortirez si
elle est mauvaise vous sortirez comme
thierry bon ça en fait à tous cas la
pression
le pire c'est quand vous dites vous
sortirez comme thierry moreau et partir
comme un prince quelque chose en fait
vous savez ce qu'elle boive les filles
dans le clip non vin de l'aude pologne
ouais
attendez on va attendre c'est twitter
qui va décider sur twitter où nous dit
est ce qu'on doit sortir gad elmaleh ou
pas parce qu'ici je pense que dans votre
émission vous devriez créer un truc qui
est entre tu sauras tu sors pas savoir
est où le mec le mec et punis sinon
c'est trop radical c'est trop manichéen
c'est trop tout noir ou blanc tu vois
c'est comme de quoi c'est comme tu
zappes tu mates il devrait avoir un truc
entre les deux puma 12,9
ça veut dire
je regarde de temps en temps je regarde
pas je me les salaires parce que je
crois pas qu'à zapper mater on va le
faire on va le faire parce que moins d
émissions que je n'aime pas où je n'irai
jamais mais que j'aime regarder c'est ça
mais c'est l'esma
je la sma allez je vous rappelle que ça
twitte un gars qui a les dents qui nous
dit nous ne sortait pas gâtés ils
veulent pas que vous sortiez sur votre
blague il ya cédric qui directement les
toi tu as des tweets imprimé en fait
haski
il mettrait tweet suivre les tweets
jeudi via une imprimante dans son iphone
sir j'ai reçu un tweet qui reste sa
blague était drôlement subtil puisque
lui l'écoutaient europe 1 il céderait
qu'il est sûre les deux os tpe europe ya
c'est celle qui dit tpv gad c'est trop
bon merci à max qui dit déjà que tp
c'est du bonheur mais ce soir c'est
juste énorme merci marie léa seydoux n'a
pas réagi un enfant où l'attend avec
impatience ion